we werewolves so admire your town and we
just came here to join your school
zombies to look like it was a blast to
film but things aren't always fun and
games Disney Channel stars have serious
guidelines they have to follow
especially when filming a highly
anticipated sequel like zombies - what
are the cast members allowed to post on
social media and which rule forced
actors to get their beauty sleep during
the day keep watching to find out the 10
strict rules the cast of zombies - had
to follow Disney Channel is really
serious about keeping their projects a
secret they only release the details
that they want - there are never leaked
photos or videos from the set and the
stars never say anything they aren't
supposed to zombies - wasn't announced
until February 2019 just a year before
the movie was set to release Milo
Manheim was given the honor of
announcing it but that was the last
anyone heard for a while slowly we found
out that there would be werewolf's in
the movie and that Addison and Ted would
have some drama but the cast wasn't
allowed to talk about anything else no
one even knew the true plot of the movie
until it was released the cast and crew
are prohibited from even sharing behind
the scenes photos until Disney says it's
okay they filmed all last summer but
they had to keep their social media on
lockdown it must be difficult to keep
such an exciting project under wraps
like that we are glad that the movie is
out so we can finally know what life was
like during the filming process
if you watch meg Donnelly and Milo
Manheim being interviewed you'll notice
that they act a lot like Addison and Zed
they might actually be that peppy all
the time but Disney Channel has a rule
for their stars they have to keep up a
certain image around the clock it's
important for Disney that everything and
everyone fits into their brand part of
Disney Channel's brand is having
happy-go-lucky bubbly stars this means
that many Disney Channel stars have felt
like they have to hide their true selves
now we don't doubt that the cast of
zombies too is made up of fun wonderful
people but it can't be easy to always be
playing a part
anytime they are on video whether it's
on their social media or in an interview
they have to act a certain way many
Disney Channel stars completely rebrand
themselves once their contracts are up
it will be interesting to see how these
stars turn out after their Disney
Channel days are over
I'm so excited to see well one of the
best parts of zombies too is the dancing
the dance numbers are incredible it's a
lot of fun watching the cast break out
into song and dance but it takes a lot
of work to make those perfect dance
routines look natural before they ever
started filming the cast had to go to a
dancing boot camp they arrived in
Vancouver a full four weeks before the
first day of shooting and they spent
long hours every single day learning and
perfecting the dance routines actors who
missed out on a day had to catch up on
their own Arielle Martin had to arrive
three days late to rehearsals and she
was nervous but Meg and the other
werewolves helped teach her the
choreography she had missed
we're glad she had such great cast mates
it would have been difficult to come
into rehearsal absolutely clueless the
actors spent a month learning those
dance numbers perfectly they were more
than ready by the time filming started
but it still took several takes for each
song they pulled it off though the
dancing looks completely natural in the
final cut
[Music]
the creative team for zombies too had an
amazing attention to detail and a lot of
effort went into making the werewolves
as authentic as possible
in typical werewolf lore werewolves
can't touch silver sometimes it causes
slight discomfort and in other stories
its fatal in zombies too the werewolves
are allergic to silver they couldn't
have any jewelry or accessories that
even look silver silver the werewolves
in the zombies were allowed to have some
say in their costumes they could add
their own Flair that they thought fit
the characters but if they accidentally
slipped on a silver ring the costume
team would freak out they also had to
deal with other makeup and costume
details these lets the werewolves having
to be in the makeup chair at around 5
a.m. every day becoming a werewolf it
took about three hours thankfully if the
actors were good sports about all of it
but we know that part couldn't have been
fun I mean Zetas and shippers were
thrilled that Zed and Addison finally
took their relationship to the next step
in zombies - at the end of the movie
those two locked lips fans everywhere
were thrilled but filming a scene like
that requires many guidelines the
kissing scene took about eight takes to
get just right first of all it's a
Disney Channel movie it can't be too
sensual or inappropriate but it also
needs to look authentic which can be a
difficult balance to strike then it has
to look good on camera in real life it's
not always glamorous but Megan Milo had
to be in exactly the right positions
Milo couldn't block her face too much
even though he is a lot taller than her
she had to make sure her nose didn't get
squished - that's why stars always say
that filming the perfect smooch is
anything but romantic there are a ton of
people around telling them how to get it
just right we're just glad it looks
natural and romantic in the final cut of
the movie
not only is it important that the Stars
keep movie details under wraps but they
are also limited on anything else they
say Disney Channel stars cannot
criticize anything about the movie or
the company it's actually in their
contract and they can lose their jobs if
they do you'll notice from interviews
that the cast of zombies too only has
positive things to say about the movie
even when they talk about the hectic
filming schedule or getting their makeup
done they keep their comments on the
sunny side it was an amazing experience
while we're sure they did have a great
time filming a movie isn't always
rainbows and butterflies there are
things that aren't enjoyable just like
with any job because they work for
Disney Channel they can't say anything
bad
they can't even sound like they might be
criticizing the process Disney is
probably a little extreme when it comes
to this rule but they want all the fans
to think life as a Disney Channel star
is perfect what rule was actually
enjoyable for the zombies to cast keep
watching to find out we can crush it
maybe we can't make the rules but we can
break them some Disney Channel movies
have very few scenes that take place at
night but that's not the case with
zombies - zombies and werewolves are
creatures of the night that means many
of these scenes and musical numbers had
to be filmed after the Sun went down we
aren't talking about a couple of hours
after dinner either
these filming sequences often took all
night even though many of the actors are
still kids
it didn't matter they had to be up late
all the time but they still had plenty
of scenes to film during the day - this
cast wasn't getting a lot of sleep
sometimes not everyone was required to
be on set it depended on which scene was
being filmed but in order to hang out
with each other many of them went to set
on their nights off if you're already
missing out on regular sleep you might
as well fully commit right the cast got
by on cat naps and caught up on sleep
during the day when possible becoming a
Disney Channel star means giving up a
lot of your individual freedom Disney
Channel contracts are strict and they
require actors to commit completely
Disney Channel even controls what the
Stars can post on their social media we
don't just mean post about the movies
therein that's an important part of it
but you texted hope they can't post
spoilers or any behind-the-scenes
details Disney doesn't want leaked but
the rest of their posts are monitored by
Disney - they can't represent brands
that Disney doesn't approve of they
can't post aspects of their life that
are too serious and they can't be too
controversial everything they post on
any platform has to fit the image of a
perfect Disney Channel star even if it's
not entirely true Disney Channel even
controls what its stars wear in public
they can't wear anything deemed too
appropriate or revealing even on their
own time this is the case for every star
including the cast of zombies -
beautiful zombies and zombies - are
somewhat different from other Disney
Channel Original Movies the cast of each
movie was allowed a degree of creative
freedom they wanted the characters to
feel authentic in zombies the zombies
were able to spice up the costumes they
added elements that they liked and
wanted but it had to fit a few
guidelines first of all it had to make
sense for the character it also had to
fit with the general vibe of the zombies
costumes and makeup zombie football star
presidential hopeful the werewolf's had
the same freedom with some restrictions
anything they added needed to fit a
certain color scheme and style but they
could add things to their costume the
cast was also allowed to add their own
spin to their dance moves
as long as they followed the general
choreography they could move their arms
or legs in ways that felt natural
again this had to fit their individual
character this creative freedom made all
the characters come alive and feel
original it was important because the
message of the franchise is that being
an individual matters disney channel
wants its cast members to be close
friends it helps boost their image of a
positive friendly company for kids and
teens so cast bonding is never
discouraged the zombies to cast took
this very seriously
a lot of their bonding moments were
self-imposed in the first movie they
hosted a bunch of dance parties they
continued that tradition on zombies -
they also hosted a bunch of game nights
after rehearsals or during time off
while filming they would play all sorts
of board games together they also had
pool parties the returning cast wasn't
about to exclude the werewolf's either
they were invited to hang out
with everyone on the very first day we'd
love that they are all such great
friends it also made the movie so much
better because they all had great
chemistry which rule would be the
hardest for you to follow let us know in
the comments that's a wrap
give this video a thumbs up and click
that subscribe button thanks for
watching we'll see you next time on the
things
[Music]